[Music]
okay so I always start this podcast
asking the Gesta for friends and then
you have to answer so that I don't know
it's our friends good are we going yeah
we're rolling whatever you want
oh my god yeah I thought you were like I
thought you're like prepping me before
not like a man so it's like when we get
live I'm gonna ask you for friends just
let me know
you know I actually really think we are
because well okay this is well so we
should start right away I don't believe
in time like I don't think like I don't
think it's like whoa we logged because
there are people that I know for years
lassic seven years eight years and then
I'll have a certain conversation with
them I'm like oh you don't know me at
all you don't know me at all
you know we are strange and I think
comics I think that comics in general
can have an intimacy like I think
there's just like a general thing if
like I think it depends on the work to
like what kind of comedy are you doing
or kind of leading with what you're
going through you you know what you
believe whatever might be but I feel
like yeah the first time we hung at
flappers my favorite Club in LA the best
it really is like I I thought my whole
life special that everything I've worked
I worked so much so much in my material
there they were the place that would put
me up and I was just excited to get on
stage when I first moved to LA and so
you who rooms legendary but I think that
I just member the first time we hung out
I think we just talked for like a couple
hours I was talking about because you
were asking me a question about my set
and then we started talking about
relationships we start talking about all
this stuff and then I think there's just
been like a couple of moments where
we'll whether it be like we FaceTime or
text or whatever and we're like I just
the quality of conversation is good so
it we're friends
we're new old friends we're new old
friend or new which is really hard to do
you know but I always say and I think
this is part of the reason I struggle in
some of my relationships and I'm always
accused of having like intimacy issues
in relationships which is
Oh cute I don't believe in intimacy this
is my new hot take of I've taken a lover
in quarantine and this whole like you're
afraid of intimacy like or I don't want
to be in a relationship with you right
now
right what is that okay like why do I
have to have like be a pathologically
flaw just because I don't want to be
with you well I think it depends on is
it the same wall that euro is hitting or
is it a wall that you want to get past
em hmm so I mean it maybe it isn't an
issue if you don't want to be intimate
also what is your and then I and then I
go into like what's your definition of
intimacy why do you need so much for me
like what are you getting your internal
needs met internally like maybe I just
have strong boundaries and I get my
internal needs met on my own like yeah I
like dude I feel very fulfilled from my
podcast that's all I need from us I have
a rotating guess I tell them when to
come and when to leave and we publicly
broadcast all of our interactions which
is like tell me about your relationship
with your mom and you're like dude start
a podcast to me crying in front of you
and not the crew it is just like
slightly exactly it is yeah I am only
intimate for public consumption
but I ask because I always want be an
issue as your new old friend not to
throw another accusation I'm more a mere
suggestion it might be I feel like I'm
just at the point where men have I've
spent so much time blaming myself for
relationships not working and because
the narrative has always been like women
are crazy women are psycho women are
dramatic like that's what I was taught
that's what I saw that's what I
internalized women are sensitive women
need to relax all this stuff that
whenever a man accuses me of something I
just assume they're right like yeah I
must have intimacy right like where I
just have strong boundaries or it's
taking me so long it's no secret that
I'm in the 12-step program it's taking
me so long to be able to just say like I
don't want to without guilt yes it's
really hard to say that because I've
also been conditioned
- if you bruise a man's ego you're gonna
be in physical danger yeah so I'm just
gonna go with your your interpretation
yeah yeah yeah yes I mean I think in in
yeah I think certainly a lot of those
things aren't aren't your issues like
they aren't you know so it's it's it's
really also - like you're a dope person
and you need someone who's gonna be at
that level and there's probably not a
ton of people who are I mean you know it
sounds like there's just certain things
that like you need your filter is gonna
be really high and so I think you might
just be a player and that's okay like
you know I mean like this feels like you
have intimacy issues you're like no I'm
just kind of I just want to hook up with
you yeah it's like a body only thing
dude like I'm the monster that I've been
trying to open this thing where it's
like is there any point and and it gets
really tricky but it's like I think
everyone has different rules around if
they want to be physically intimate
without the emotional part yeah and so I
think it's a really that's a tough line
that's like that's the line that I've
constantly been having to define for
myself and like and try to understand
you know what are the rules that you
want to have around that and and what do
you want that to look like because
because it gets messy right because you
you get naked with somebody or you get
into that space and then they say
something like hey you're not intimate
or you're not you know you have any
tipsy issue or whatever might be it's
like you open something up and it's like
you don't even know who you opened it up
to you know what I mean there's like you
let someone in your house and then
they're like oh like the ventilations
off and this is weird and or whatever
and I'm like you're like no I don't even
let this person in you know and what if
somebody notes on my home I also think I
also know my cell phone is because I
identify as an addict that's no secret
to anyone like I know that I can become
chemically addicted to someone before I
like them yeah or think that they're
right like I know myself so I like have
to be so careful because I can but
mine's the opposite I don't have
intimacy issues I can actually form a
very tight intimate trauma bond with a
literal criminal mm-hmm like left to my
own devices it's to me I think that to
pathologize to conflate intimacy issues
with trying to take it at a slow healthy
a duck DePace is when I get frustrated
I'm like just cuz I'm taking my time
right get to know you before I get all
like lost in the oxytocin dopamine
fuckin hook mm-hmm I'd like to just yeah
you want to get to ya know the person
before you get on that level right cuz I
fall in love with so many people that I
didn't like yeah and it's exhausting
yeah agency oh we also want to know like
what their setup is you wanna know what
they care about you wanna what their
family's car just let you create all
that stuff so I think you should just do
with the Muslim way where you guys don't
even mean I it's not even the you don't
even know look I I have so many friends
that have look everything's to varying
degrees of success
right going on tinder walking into a bar
or doing something that's like very
family heavy first or whatever that
everyone has different families so it's
hard to say what that would look like
for a lot of people but there's a lot of
ways where people everyone's taken a
stab at I want to know more before I
really give in you know because when you
really give in facts go out the window
boundaries go out the window it's it's
you're doing it dant it's like it's like
you're on a tightrope walk with someone
else you know and and and are they gonna
yeah sway that wire you know you really
got to trust that I the reason I brought
all this up is because I'm really glad
that we met before I saw your show
because I just finished the second
season and I it would have fucked up our
chances of being friends because I would
have been like a fan I'm serious that's
how good the show is and it's on Hulu
you you have you have to see it and it
this is how good the show is this is the
highest praise I can give a piece of
work which is that it's so good that I
stopped being jealous and just got to
watch it it enjoy it as a fan no truly
because it's like as a comedian as
someone in television you either hate
something because you're like I get
tested for that or Elmas got that job or
that this person and I used to work
together and it was a disaster or I see
the ADR or the looping or the battery
whatever like it's really hard to enjoy
it without seeing all the machinations
and all them sort of like behind the
scenes stuff is always see and or you
watch something in your life jealous
it's very rare that with what I do for a
living I'm able to watch a show like as
a fan that's really sweet and I'm not
sweet it's just I'm not happy about this
compliment it makes me angry that's how
good it is and I think it like
exemplifies the idea of as an artist the
more specific you are the more universal
you are and it was so wild to me
that it really it's a it becomes a
Rorschach test like you could anyone
it's so specifically about your
experience but also so much felt like oh
yeah that my mom does that shit might
like it's just right how incredibly
because as a comedian you're always like
well I want to appeal to everybody like
yeah I'm gonna do jokes about airplane
food I'm gonna be do jokes about all
religions jokes about this so that
everyone will like me and the key is
just being so specific we're just we're
just getting into it we're just kind of
just getting the hang of that because I
remember talking about my show I think I
was talking about what I wanted to do
like with an all Muslim family Arab
Muslim family in like 2013-2014 I
remember talking about it with reps and
stuff and everyone just kind of being
like I don't know do like maybe they
should have a white maybe their
neighbors white family like maybe like
someone walked it maybe it's an exchange
student you know just pitching you like
everything under the Sun that kind of
makes no sense and then how could we
have as few Muslims in it as pop yeah
yeah there'd be like oh cool but like
what if no yeah but no and and then you
know cuz I kind of keep really saying
Hollywood it's it's it's so tricky
because there's this idea that Hollywood
is pushing social change but social
change pushes Hollywood that's right no
one really wanted to greenlight a show
about an Arab Muslim family until Trump
said here's a list of countries that
people shouldn't be allowed to come from
that's really when people who are you
know on the right side of things like
actually maybe we need to get to know
these people a little bit more and so so
there's this um there's been this fear
of specificity but for me I've been
surprised
even in making it like I remember
sending the pilot to friends and hearing
things that were just wild to me like my
buddy was just like dude this reminds me
of Jamaicans
you know and and and that that's the
kind of thing you don't expect yeah it's
the kind of thing where where there's
articles that are like this is the most
Jewish show on TV there's there's kids
in Egypt like love the show so much and
they're not American you know they're
and and and that's a that's been a
baffling one for me because I'm almost
like well that's a country where there's
no novelty I'm over watching a show
that's in Arabic or watching a show with
Muslims right that novelties gone yeah
so they're only looking at really what
we're doing with the story and they're
connecting and I think the exciting
thing has been just creating these
characters and this family where we're
looking at people where they hide mm-hmm
and everybody hides we're looking at
people like Hannah between this gap of
who they want to be and who they
actually are and that's all of us you
know and also it's like you know again I
I mean it's no secret I'm in a 12-step
program which is we say god it is a
spiritual program like you know I feel
like to me I'm watching this show about
someone who is just trying to get their
carnal proclivities under control like
the daily whack-a-mole of like how do I
manage my selfishness and my most sort
of reprehensible impulses and then
manage that shame I mean that's us all
of us all day every day yeah and I think
also what's amazing for someone like you
being in a 12-step program kind of being
actively I mean we've talked about you
know I go to therapy at night yeah you
know it's a big part of my life but I
think a lot of us don't know the issue
that we're really facing I think this
show does look at yes you know with this
character he I think because of various
societal things it's not really just
because of his religion it's also just
kind of a society that we're living in
he's dealing with the emotional sexual
addiction type things that are
underlying but they get kind of like
hidden you know and they get kind of
turned into oh well he's just a bad
person or this person just did that or
oh there's nothing wrong with a little
bit of porn or oh this is just how
people hook up or whatever it might be
and we're all really a lot of times
masks
really serious thing so this is this
amazing clarity of someone like you
being in a 12-step and you know things
that I know about you of just you know
understanding patterns of addiction
early on you kind of are very aware of
it right but but a lot of people aren't
a lot of people don't know what's going
on a lot of people aren't and like
addiction you know it's it's fascinating
I was watching this tonight and I'm
whatever I'm not really a big like spoil
or like I know spoilers and I watched
something and I still enjoy it but I
also do that I'm a writer I actually
like to know what happens so that I
could just enjoy the execution of it and
I don't have to deal with the tension
wondering what's gonna happen so I
allowed of times look up spoilers but I
don't want to spoil it for everyone
because the experience is you are such a
master of tension and and you really
bring someone to the brink of discomfort
to have to make them look at their own
beliefs and it is it was there was a
couple I'll just say the Atlantic City
episode I had to pause and take a while
and that to me is where veers into
performance art and some people are
cringing some people are laughing some
people are upset some people are angry
like it really does hold up a mirror
wild like the people get pissed about my
show cuz feelings come up you're making
them feel stuff entus people I think a
lot of times want to go well all we're
trying to do all day is anesthetize our
pain that's all we're doing all day
right that's our that is our only goal
all day is to not feel pain that's all
we try to do anger TV sex food whatever
it is it's the whack-a-mole of life and
your show is just and it's so funny and
it's warm and it's it's and then you're
like oh no you're gonna look at your
shit the same way this character is
looking at their shit and you're gonna
just hold on the character you're not
cutting away you're not there's no
respite from the tension and it really I
laugh when I'm sad
yeah or uncomfortable and I realize like
how much deep section I still is someone
that talks about sex for a living is I'm
just known for talking about sex
the amount of discomfort I still have
around it is yeah fascinating we have no
we just have such a such a lack of
shared language
real understanding of what it is and we
this country America is one of the most
sexually dur plus repressed places on
earth you know I mean it's like it's the
middle east gets that rap but it's so
it's so fascinating I have so many
people in my life who buy culture kids
who are you know and a lot of women I
talk to who are like I don't know how to
describe to you I feel safer in Saudi
than in Brooklyn mm-hmm and they're like
they're like don't ask me why I know
that this and that and that there's
certain things that whatever like they
get it they get the joke they're not
like they get ya know how crazy this
statement like that sounds um there are
a lot of underlying things here that we
don't know I mean this is something that
I rift about on stage of just talking
about like yeah we don't know what sex
is right it's like with all the stuff
that that has happened a lot of people
are like oh this is something's raping
and other people are like this is that
was the beginning of my relationship I
mean that's how we that's how we met
yeah that's how that happened I told my
wedding it's it's it's it's so wild yeah
you know it's so wild the thing that
someone would share with their kids and
then the other thing that someone was
like dude this is a super violating
emotionally manipulative thing so what
we get out with the show is we're again
looking at places where people hide and
the show is about a believing person
it's not someone who is really trying to
live up to the the aspects of their
faith and so it's super aspirational on
that and I think it's a warm show but
faith is almost just as touchy as sex
what more so I actually think if if we
could since podcast and I can go what's
your favorite sex position we could like
have that conversation I could be like
how much money did you make on your show
like the money is the other like really
taboo thing but like do you believe in
God like let's talk about God that is
oddly I think the most taboo thing that
you can talk about the most
uncomfortable thing people talk about
and I'm not really talked about it on
this show people know I'm in a 12-step
program they know the whole deal with
that I can't I grew up in Catholic
Christian yeah and I just have been
because I've been watching the show and
I've been thinking about a lot this week
and think about like how I'm gonna talk
about this with you because what I
realize is I had anger because growing
up in a
around Catholic I was in Catholic
schools I didn't realize until recently
and you know every religion has their
shit every religion has their
misogynistic shit every religion has
their everything like I'm not talking
about the you know creepy shit that
happens and um a lot of religion but for
me I just put together how sexualized
Catholic girls are and I don't I didn't
put it together literally it cuz the
whole store people will always talk
about like the other Catholic Church
scandal right that one so I realized at
the other day I was like as a kid I
always felt so watched or something and
now that I'm an adult
I'm sort of like when I see a girl in
the Catholic school uniform I'm just
like I get really upset and angry that
it's been sexualized yeah you know yeah
and I think that that is such a fucked
up thing that has taken me so long to
work through that shame yeah of like how
young I was accidentally made sexual
because that has become like a fantasy a
sexual fantasy like a schoolgirl thing
like I still see you see you know if
it's the PTSD of it because when you go
to Halloween parties and someone's like
dressed as to school were like makes me
angry yeah and I didn't know why until
now yeah you know until I was really
thinking about it trying to unpack it
this week
I mean it's so it's it's super it's sad
like it's sad because we don't talk
about it right so it's like things are
only that alluring and attractive or
whatever might be because they're not
being discussed right so and it's really
interesting if you look at the patterns
of how America even let's just say on
like a policy we don't talk about the
guilt of things we do to other countries
and you look at even just with going
into Vietnam and in the sexualization of
Asian women you know you look at going
into the Middle East and then the
fetishization of the hijab you know you
look at these are really linked
repressed things when we're not dealing
with pain and we're not dealing with how
we treat people they become these things
we play out in pretty violent and odd
fantasies and it's not even to judge
what excites somebody but it's more to
understand it because that feeling
you're talking about that link is super
real
and it's B
cuz there's so much that's undiscussed
he said something as a child that you
can't put your you don't know it's
really happening and then till later and
then this weird like disassociation come
and then like anger comes up like I was
really thinking about it a lot this week
and my relationship to religion because
I think you know for the longest time
I'm always whatever you know I always
have like a hot take and I feel like the
cool new thing certainly with comedians
and in Hollywood it's whatever's like
these religions not religion stupid
religion that take is so annoying to me
because it is so elitist like when when
like straight white guys in Hollywood
religions fucking stupid it's like yeah
you don't need hope your life is great
you know what I'm saying it drives me
fucking insane or just like yeah you
don't need a sense of community you
don't need a place to take your kids you
know so they can meet other kids like
you've got nannies like nuts you know
like you don't need sort of someone to a
sense of like what's gonna happen after
this because life is so fucking what's
this thing where a lot of and on a
Hollywood level even just the group
you're talking about so much of this is
so independent yeah so much of this is
so without a roadmap that the easy trick
is you don't need to believe in God
because you start to just believe in
yourself that's right and you just start
to kind of but but worship yourself
that's right and not even look at how
you got what you got and so it's such a
convenient trick because you're like
well oh I did all this hard work course
but you're like yeah but like what
cleared the path for that what like what
is this table I mean like me I'm - I get
to down those rabbit holes to even like
something I'm not proud of anything I've
done but I'm like am I really gonna sit
here and worship me and I worship like
how this thing happened when I know we
all know anybody who's even like gotten
near any sort of success know how lucky
we are oh that's already fucking lucky
we are and how many people we know who
are smarter and do it and like all those
things at every step of the way and so I
see why people say that I see why people
do that but I also kind of him like dude
how can you fall for that yeah like how
do you fall for that trick like it's not
there's Sun it's so funny because this
is I was targeted
guy friends and and you know there's a
big like movement towards people wanting
to say like we're in a simulation I my
reaction was like like is your I worked
for this I mean like I also worked hard
for this the idea of like well this is
just a simulation like whatever it's
like that's how lucky you've been that
you're like I want credit for what I've
achieved I don't wanna be like if some
guys just playing a video game and
that's why I'm successful like can I at
least have the win can I you know like
it's just like yeah I feel like I feel
like Islands the bad feel like girls in
their twenties are gonna have to like
argue with guys like being like so where
were you last night I don't know we're
in a simulation and I just I don't even
know so I cheated but it was simulated
but like someone else is playing me in a
game like how Elon Musk's describes
cheating he's like I'm come on like it's
not it was simulated I mean I didn't do
that
you know how in touch I am with
overlords you know it was an algorithm
like I didn't even choose that like I
know that code I came up with in March
and the way that that's completely
infiltrated my senses pretty dope that's
actually it's it's in the future I put
that in your bag no I was thinking about
you that because it's not not a
simulation it's just I think I think I
think everyone is everyone wants to kind
of arrive it like they're convenient
yeah this must be right that's right and
I'm religious person I believe in Islam
yeah and III will tell you the greatest
teachers that I know you'll ask them
certain things and they'll be like yeah
I don't know I gotta think about that
yeah you know me like like there's this
well that was certainty is such a such a
killer you know and I'm not saying that
there aren't certain things that are
right or wrong and I'm not saying that
we're all not trying to like deal with
those things but the the certainty that
we kind of like walk around with as a
society right now isn't just about the
truth of the principle it comes with
this crazy judgment and it comes with
this crazy leverage that
this is what I think is right or this
might even be what is principally right
and now I'm gonna abuse you
yeah the fact that that's the truth
that's right it's the truth can't just
exist
everyone wants ownership over it and
everyone uses the truth to kind of
perpetuate this form of abuse and and
it's this weird thing because when
people do something wrong there's almost
no path back in certain people's eyes
because that's their relationship with
the truth and so it sometimes I feel
like we're living in like a Marvel movie
yeah well there's just heroes in there's
villains and it's like how could you be
anything else which is why as someone
who is not super well-read and and as a
kin is a comedian anything that I ever
do like I can't it's about playing in
the grey yeah you know I'm not trying to
give people an answer about anything I'm
just trying to bring people closer to
their questions because I think we all
have a lot of questions and I don't
think that we're always actively trying
to answer them I think we're trying to
numb ourselves now it's right that's
we're trying to hide them and so I think
there's this idea that oh we're all
seeking and it's like maybe but I think
we're also like idling trying to not
seek we're really trying to just pass
the time and also have some kind of you
know I'm really obsessed with terror
management theory and you know it terror
management chuttan
is the explanation for a lot of really
nasty things that humans do right
basically that we're just trying to
manage our existential dread everyday
because we're one of the only animals
that knows they're gonna die like we
know you know so we need you know things
to distract us from our mortality and
make us feel like we are going to have
some kind of posterity and that's why I
started playing Animal Crossing yeah was
exactly that I was like I think I need
to I need an island on this Animal
Crossing thing and I just dressed my
dude up and go fishing see I just
released an update where you jump in the
water and swim and I lost my mind I was
like this is my week is good now because
I'm gonna swim in Animal Crossing I mean
this is that I don't I don't know that
one is that the same as farmville
probably I don't know I'm in a very
narrow way I I have so much I think too
much compassion I think for humans
sometimes it maybe it's because I do so
much work with animals because I'm
obsessed with fear and how
fear drives our decisions and managing
fear because I realized that I lied to
you the other day mmm
I have an amends to make with you we
were on a hike and you asked me a
question and I went into autopilot and I
gave a bullshit answer oh cool I mean I
thought about it cuz I just went into
autopilot because you know one of my
drugs is talking one of my ways that I
manipulate myself one of the ways that I
try to control other people's behavior
which it doesn't work it's a drug it's
an illusion hallucination one of the
ways that I anesthetize myself is
talking right and deal with discomfort
in fear whatever rationalize minimize
micromanage mother all of it martyr a
lot of work a lot of work a lot of words
I'm just having a seizure yeah you asked
me we were having such a good time I was
and I feel I feel very like I don't feel
like I have to perform around you I
don't feel as you can tell but it's
podcast I'm not really trying to be felt
like I feel like I can be authentic
around you I feel very safe around you I
don't feel like I have to make myself
smaller around you make myself funny or
like I it's just like but you asked me a
question you said why do you do this
right right right and I gave some
autopilot press junket answer that I
like I like as I was giving it I was
like out-of-body looking at myself being
like you phony bitch like I was just
like what are you saying
I was just like and I and what I said
wasn't I said something about being of
service right because in your like I was
kind of tied to when we were talking
about 12-step kind of stuff yeah yeah
and being of service is the whole deal
of like to build self-esteem you have to
do a steep mobile action so that's like
sort of the whole thing and program and
why being of service it's like you know
to me that's where God whatever whatever
version of God you believe in is is
instead of thinking about myself I'm
gonna be of service to someone else
without any strings attached without
keeping score whatever I'm gonna reach
handle my selfish energy into being of
service someone else cooperation
and productivity makes dopamine I feel
good I'm back to their logical stasis
right because I'm an addict so I like
the biological basis for why religion
helps people I can you know for people
to want to go Luke dotes fucking on
science like there's scientific you know
so I was like I think it's to be of
service no that's true like the true
answer because I feel like I owe you
like is that I think I do this because
it's how you know someone once said that
comedians become comedians to control
how they get embarrassed or how they get
loud at school like I think because my
biggest fear in life is being
embarrassed because I was embarrassed so
much as a kid not only because growing
up and alcoholic home and all the like
embarrassing things that you have to
like be like oh no that she's just tired
or oh no she's or all the stuff you're
covering up but also I think part of
growing up Catholic was a lot of
embarrassing I had on the wrong uniform
I hat you know yeah I did things wrong
I'm sinning I'm fucking up whatever but
I think the gross embarrassed ironically
embarrassing answer is I think I do this
to show the grossest parts myself so no
one can like get me yeah I said it
already said it right I know yeah you
the point I don't have any secret like
in we say in program you're only as sick
as the secrets you keep it's like I keep
having secrets is so intolerable to me
the discomfort is so intense the shame
is so overwhelming and that is the
engine of all of the worst things I've
ever done is that having a secret
whether it's eating sex bad
relationships
micromanaging etc but I think that's the
true answer hmm and I felt really dirty
ever since I gave you that fake answer
well you know you the answer you gave me
wasn't fake it was just the it was
another part of it like that morning it
was I I felt like yeah but also but also
like you know it was hot out you know
we're on a hike and sometimes it's hot
out if we were on the way you ask me
that way when I was hydrated would have
been the surrounding
Milo is a blood-sugar ask you at a point
where we were like how long almost
longer is this thing going anyone could
have done what you did an opener toward
the app yeah yeah this is your fault
like I do blame you situation shaming
yeah and then I don't think you answered
no I think I did I was talking about a
little bit of what we're talking about -
so what you just said is part of it for
me for sure yeah
it's part of it you know as a Catholic
girl I felt it's part of it for me where
this idea of yeah it's there's a control
element right where you want and you you
wouldn't want someone to it's almost
like I because I got to exercise a lot
of that through stand-up yeah it's less
even in like my public work I I don't
know if we talked about this I did most
of my work for like a lot of years
without ever putting anything online and
I never put anything out until I think
my first stand-up clip was my late-night
clip those like my first clip over yeah
the first time I ever had anything I
might have had like one other small clip
but I wasn't I I very quickly stopped
making things for the Internet
I kind of was just like okay I'm gonna
spend this time just being in front of
people and a lot of what you just
described was a big part of it where I
was like I want to point out my
insecurities so I have another ship over
them so it's like I got to that stage
and then like that that happened and
that felt good but then it started and
then after that like people making fun
of me about certain things or whatever
you know how Twitter gets about anything
you know it's it's it's oh it's a whole
lotta great oh that's good and I have I
have like my main Twitter which I'll
like check every couple days my real
Twitter though is like only NBA and
Animal Crossing I can just go on and
it's like or two higher powers yo I like
truly like I go on and it's like I
follow all these accounts that's like
they're like 23 year olds around the
world who are just like showing you
their designs you know and it's weird
it's like oh like I'm 29 but it's the
only time where I feel weird I'm like
what am i doing
we're all our avatars and stuff and
everyone's like here's a you know a cool
design I made for my backyard but it's
not a real yard it's a lacrosse but I
got kind of past the the whole thing
with it I think with the certain things
I knew I wanted to start talking about
the things that I really felt this gap
on was I wanted to make something about
someone who was believing because I
remember doing stand-up during Ramadan
and actually talking about you know what
I was thinking and what I was feeling
and that I was fasting now because my
parents made me do it and I said it and
it felt like punk rock you know like I
went on stage after this to do it really
just like oh I just did oh man the other
night I did shrooms and I put this woman
in the back seat of my car I put her in
the trunk of my car he said it was like
this whole crazy bit I'm not gonna say
who the comic was but you did this crazy
he did this crazy bit and I'm like I was
watching that bit and I'm like watching
a liberal bar in Brooklyn laughs and and
I'm like horriffic ation of scummy Ness
of just like I mean he's saying it in
jest or whatever but I'm like what are
you getting at I remember just being
like what's happening and but this was
like 24 you left that you put on a shirt
your voice is loudest you put on you got
in the car you paid for a cab to say
that dude and I'm watching and I'm like
and this is 2015 2014 so it's like
before people care about this kind of
stuff yeah and you know and and I'm but
I'm like I'm not saying I'm sitting
there wagging my finger anything yeah
like whatever I we've all heard
everything so I'm not I'm not actually
not positioned to what this person is
doing on a comedy level I'm just bored
mm-hm yeah yeah yeah so I'm not sitting
here being like on the drug hurt it
towards her frankly hurt me so much it's
not that I disapprove I've just heard it
so many times I grew up in Jersey that's
always my favorite thing anyway but you
know so I'm like I'm just bored and
anyway I go up and I talk about what
what's actually and it feels like whoa
feels like I just talked about doing
drugs and putting
in the car and I just said I'm fasting
Ramadan because no one made me and and
so I I kind of saw that and it's like
most gangster shit you can say oh yeah
dude thank God for this company because
water is so gross to me you do hate it
so much like the only way I would drink
it as a kid as if there was like my
let's say kool-aid
in an ad that's not work-related if
there was fruit flavoring in it
powdering some kind of powder in it
finally there's like a healthy way that
you could make water taste good that's
not pure sugar
it's called hydrant and it's an
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into the water so that you hide hydrates
better which is why I look so hydrated
and they are delicious too they have
four essential electrolytes your body's
needs sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc yes which is probably why I'm not
getting sick to be honest putting up
with your migraines - yeah oh that's a
really good and just like my energy
because there's one that also yeah if
you need to boost your energy they have
one that has its hydrant plus caffeine
yeah that's a good one to do in the
morning contains a hundred milligrams of
caffeine from green tea hydrant is
backed by research thank God the formula
was developed by an Oxford scientist is
he single or she it's also loved by pro
athletes top performer celebrities and
thousands of five-star reviews it's made
with real fruit juice powder delicious
refreshing comes in many flavors I like
the pink one the grapefruit one I like
the iced tea lemonade cuz I'm from the
thigh out analogy I like to sit on my
porch have a little I actually like that
with some there's a lemonade that I get
and I just put the iced tea one in and I
make like a little Arnold Palmer I know
that's delicious wait is he cancelled
was he bad we don't know him okay we
don't know him I've never met her I'm
sure something soon surface if you don't
like this product it's a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed or you can send
it back if you don't love it for a full
recall so you can carry them around in
your purse and they don't explode oh
yeah which is actually I put mine in my
pocket yeah and then you can just like
wherever you go if you go to a
restaurant you can like pop it in make
your water tasty cuz I will not drink
water unless these around that it's
really sad but I'm so
brat and I hate the taste of water well
that's okay you don't have to like it
anymore
we've solved it starts at just one buck
a packet for a 30-day supply even more
with a monthly subscription take care of
your immune system we've talked about
this on the show you've got to hydrate
yourself it's gonna be a super super hot
summer you have got to get water in your
body we've got a special deal for our
listeners to save 25% off your first
order go to drink hydrant calm / Whitney
or enter our promo code Whitney and
check out that strength hydrant dot-com
/ Whitney and enter promo code Whitney
for 25% off your first order drink
hydrant calm / Whitney and enter the
promo code Whitney - save 25% off we
thank them for sponsoring this podcast
seven times in a row hello French hey
fresh - hello fresh now I know that some
people really like to cook yeah and
that's like their thing it's a joint
going to the grocery store getting the I
think it's a hassle it is a hassle I
think it's a waste of time I forget
something every time I think it's
frankly not feminist oh I would like all
the ingredients and the recipe all there
I just want to put it in the thing yeah
you're right I want to live like royalty
that's right
I want to feel like I have a chef what I
don't you can't with hellofresh to
become your own chef it's the number one
milk in America so hello fresh offers
fresh high-quality ingredients every
week for a super flavorful experience
something for everyone there's low
calorie vegetarian family-friendly
recipes
it's pre-portioned look I'm just gonna
cut to it you guys know me I'm not a
phony faker I don't know how to cook
there I said it and you were full of
nuts for a long time I don't know how to
cook hello fresh is the only way that I
can make something edible
okay the whole time I thought I was here
with Rachael Ray you know and it makes
it very easy they deliver the
ingredients they deliver the food you
don't have to be a math elite you don't
have to have measuring cups you don't
have to have a protractor
you don't have to have all those weird
tools you have to have a mailing address
and a kitchen that's all you need
that's all Union even better than that
hellofresh is also giving back
hellofresh is committed to making fresh
delicious food available now more than
ever and it's taken extra steps to keep
its employees and customers safe awesome
hello fresh doughnut donated over 2.5
million meals to charity and eat our
meals meal meals to charity they done
into them so right now you can go to
hello fresh comm / good for you eighty
full belly and good karma good for you
80 is the code eight zero hello fresh
dot-com / good for you eighty eight zero
the name of this show and the decade
your hairstyle came from so you can use
the code good for you eighty to get a
total of $80 off oh that makes more
sense including free shipping in your
first box that's hello fresh calm such
good for you eighty and use code good
for you eighty to get a total of $80 off
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hello Russian icon for more
details hello fresh I had a bit about
going to the mosque after you know the
there was the shooting at the Moscone
and and in in New Zealand and just how
it was just like the coolest moment of
my life just like I haven't even gotten
your special feelings on HBO I I hate
telling comics how funny their specials
are cuz I'm like because well here's
thing I normally would just wouldn't say
anything right right that's my new thing
because when you like your session was
still funny
I my eye are you that your special has
one of the biggest closers of any
special last ten years I think that it
was like a it was like a like a
lightning clap and I was like huh like
it's very rare that comics don't know
where something's go you know I mean
there were so many things where I was
like huh like I that fuck fuck like it
fuck that I would got I got angry a
couple times that's the best reaction
you get from a comedian I would say is
we don't really laugh that much but it's
like motherfucker closer I obviously
won't go it's so funny to when anything
happens with them
like it's it's
funny how inattentive we are to other
comedy - yeah it's like what's always
like some like it didn't I'm not even
talking about the serious stuff
even something small happens like some
wannabe like a little thing like oh you
didn't know that person got married like
that comedian you didn't know that
they'd and I'm like no I didn't know
like no one knows we go we do our sets
and we leave yeah I don't know I don't
know what anyone's doing yes and and and
we'll watch stuff of course but it's
just like a weird thing because I don't
think you have to worry about a lot of
comics getting married by the way I was
trying to like create like a very safe
[Laughter]
like taking the sweetest example we
don't even want to go down that why I
say that to say that yeah there is this
level of like strangers yeah it's it's
it's it's hard to watch but I can be
objective about it and I kind of know
you know as a creative I just loved
endings yeah I love them and I'm and I
and I and I know I often know what I'm
working towards the thing that I'm more
so I'm excited to kind of keep working I
was like I always kind of play with
beginnings yeah I got a that's something
that like I always knew how I wanted to
end my set now I'm talking about the
special just like even from when I
started stand-up I know what I'm
building I know what I'm building
towards like that's always exciting I
want to building towards and then like
I'm having fun figuring out how am I
gonna start helm yeah you know starting
is a crazy thing like to just the first
moment openings are like they're
everything has its own difficulty
between openings middles endings anyway
it's really hard you also miss really
hard to take a compliment but I really
appreciate you seeing worked it's hard
to take a compliment but I I was very to
bring it out I was very proud of the
ending I really initially I it was it
was just because it was fun to do
because it's just fun I felt nervous to
do it I'm still nervous there's I'm
still nervous that people go watch it
and I get in trouble you know I mean
that's why that's why I like it
because it scares me and it'll scare me
for my whole life yeah like and that is
what I
want anything I make to do and so when
you asked me you know why do I do this
it's because I want to do the things
that are going to scare me I don't want
to do it because it's convenient I don't
want to do it because it's part of any
sort of movement or any sort of moment I
want to do it because man this really
scares me and it'll always scare me
there's stuff in my show that I'm like
it'll always scare me it'll always scare
me it always makes me feel vulnerable it
always makes me feel at risk I'm always
like second guessing I never really
second-guess that I did it because but
and I would never take any of it back
but it doesn't it's not like you put I
don't want to put something out and
sleep well you know that I never want to
because my whole point is to make people
feel less alone and so if I'm not
hitting on something that doesn't feel
that kind of nerve-wracking on some
level then why am i doing it and it's
not sin it's not about sensationalism
it's almost about like can I offer up
something of myself because that's the
only thing an entertainer should be
doing it's like it's like yeah maybe
some people just want to make you laugh
that's cool I'm pretty like I feel like
my lane is to kind of offer up something
that and then you know it's for some
people it's not for other people I just
want the weirdos
because usually like weirdos like me and
I'm like cool I need such a haunted like
I'm watching the second season it feels
like it feels like going through a
haunted house and that's what life feels
like now you know in a way you know
every morning we just walked through
this funhouse like nightmare and you
know like when Mesa was had a
transgender past it I mean that the
spoiler I mean I was like so stressed
out like that's my favorite reaction you
can get from an audience member okay
like oh fuck you know the character so
well like you've done such a good job I
don't even need to know watch the scene
play out I already know this is Artie
and like everybody's right and
everybody's wrong and I'm on both sides
and it's a fair fight and I it's
something that is so hard to do I don't
think people understand how hard it is
to do right characters that do the wrong
things for the right reasons
yeah it's so hard to do like your
characters can get
can do despicable things and it makes
you love them more and that is a muscle
that I think we all need to work on
because we're watching people be
despicable constantly all the time and
then it just makes us hate them like the
fact that you're able to dimensionalize
Despicable people were there ever times
you were in there when you're like oh
this is gonna or you just go for it no
no it's just kind of yeah a ton of being
and it's funny because you watch a show
and you're like really but there's a ton
of time to work well that'll cross the
line I can't do that like she can't make
this much money she can't live in that
big of a house like well she can't like
you know she can't I mean when I have to
cast a boyfriend of myself it's so
exhausting well he's too hot for me and
he's too tall for me and like people
hate me you know I mean like just those
like those sort of Chipman barriers yeah
there's gymnastics to putting anything
out at work like for me yeah we're
constantly like making sure we're taking
the right risks and and and wanting to
and and knowing like it could work it
could not work but I have my personal
lines that I'm like okay then some it's
so instinctual to yeah it's just a
barometer that it's hard to put words
around but there's always ultimately
this thing of I want to make sure this
makes again makes people feel less
lonely but that it's contributing to the
the it's contributing the conversation
in a way that's bearing and not in a way
that is pushing people who are already
being hurt you know and and and it isn't
you know contributing in this way that
could be reductive or whatever but we
obviously do it you know in our tone and
in our way and so therefore some people
just the tone in and of itself is
offensive for some people the topic in
and of itself is offensive for some
people so so there's a lot of things
that I say we mean brings up stuff that
you're forced to have to look at sure
but some people don't even look at it
like that some people are just like well
this is just sacrilege or some people
are like well this is just you know
throw around any sort of terms like oh
you're discussing race you're racist oh
well this character did that you're
misogynist or this character do whatever
and you know a lot of words or terms to
describe people are used very freely and
are used with a lot of academic sounding
decisiveness does this I like there
there's and this is like a big part of
the conversation
online to where it's like intellect is
leveraged in this way that is so it's
like a knife you know of well I'm gonna
use a word I'm used a term I'm gonna use
a breakdown I'm gonna use a stat I'm
gonna use whatever it might be and I'm
gonna murder you with it you know and
because this is where I'm coming from
but that's why we're comedians that's
why I'm a comment cuz I'm like well this
is I made this up yeah this is a joke
yeah I want like someone will call me a
clown like it's an insult and I'm like
just found out my job it's because I I'm
so obsessed with what our next
addictions are like what we're gonna
look back in 30 years and go like oh
yeah like cuz like rehab just trying to
open up for cell phones like you know
all the things I do think come on self
righteous indignation is the next
alcoholism it's like everyone was just
like drinking martinis at lunch in the
50s and none of us called it alcoholism
that's like businessmen did we now look
that I've thought about that so much of
like just the and it's funny because I
have a streaming show but way people
watch stuff is insane like I like the
way we used to it can you believe that I
used to be like cocaine and cocaine I
really do my grandpa watch a whole show
and one day he was like you wouldn't
walk around eating get in the air like
it's wild yeah and then they went online
like just at any age they wanted to and
just started fighting with people and
what saying whatever the fuck they
wanted all day but all their info out
there they were on their screens for
seven hours a day just scrolling
scrolling scrolling they could follow
whoever they wanted without a license
without an application they couldn't you
know I mean like there was no test you
had to take like there's some crazy
thing where we look back the same way
that doctors like told pregnant women to
smoke to relax
there's work kind of look back and go I
hope can you believe we just carried
these devices around and can look at
them whenever we want it I hope I mean
it's it's without our insurance going up
I hope that there is some sort of
ethical code around yeah technology and
and around how we use these things and
it's a really difficult thing because
you don't want to stop people's freedom
but then you're also like
you're enslaving yourself to this
digital world you know in your and
you're you're putting everything into it
in this way that and it's a it's hot I'm
Egyptian and you know there was a
revolution in Cairo because of Twitter
so I'm never gonna discount what's
happening and I'm never gonna discount
how much pain is taken away from people
people who were able to come forward
about things that have happened to them
you know so that's undeniable the people
and things have gotten a lot of
connection and so and I love the
Internet but yeah I'm like man I really
hope that we can have some sort of
ethics around how we're using this stuff
just for our help well it's moderation
and it's something that I said I was
watching as shown I don't think this is
in luck once you make a show it's not
your show anymore you know it comes
whatever the intersection between it's
such a weird thing I like to put in the
world and like I'll probably say things
that it made me think of it you're like
that wasn't the intention but it's not
your show anymore my show yeah and
there's so much of watching that that
made me just be like God we are animals
like we are primal animals I think we
forget that and so much of our addictive
behaviors worked very well for us
thousands of years ago like actually
like you know they say the strongest
survive and Darwinism like addicts were
the most well equipped to survive you
know these are all tools that we got
honestly as the animals the most
addictive the ones that thought about
food the most the ones that thought
about sex the most the ones that Fox
seven times a day were the ones that
procreated the most and had the most
protection like the ones that were the
most obsessed with food and whose
dopamine receptors couldn't hold on to
dopamine in the ones that kept hunting
then once the highest risks were the
ones that went out and caught the deer
killed the bear or whatever all these
addictive impulses have served us really
well as humans but only in the last like
thirty years are these incredible tools
now backfiring and they're obsolete and
they're actually a liability right you
know and I just remember just like
watching you in the show and just being
like oh my god this is like a perfectly
designed person for like a thousand
years ago you know and we're now in this
time where all of a sudden all of these
like like anxiety when everyone's
everyone's complaining about anxiety
right another one so anxiety is why our
species proliferated I mean the most
anxious are the ones that survived the
most paranoid
the ones that like you know were the
most hyper-vigilant you had to be you
had to be you know and so it's just so
interesting to sort of think of like the
primordial reptilian forces that are at
play all the time and how you know I was
in an al-anon zoo meeting yesterday and
someone said like I am praying for God
to help me control my primal urges and
instincts because it's not something I
can do myself you know and like that's
when you turn your life over to God when
you just go like I am NOT in control of
this thing like this is so much bigger
than me this is like my ancestors this
is my species this is something that we
were wired to do like help me undo
thousands of years of wiring yeah
programming you know cultural zeitgeist
nature all of it but just sort of like
the biological elements of it yeah I
mean even like the biological elements
of like is there and you know am I being
watched is there an animal coming for me
is there like whatever or I need to find
an animal all that stuff now it for a
lot of us were not under those kinds of
you you know if you think you're being
watched or fought you all you have to do
is just like unplug your Alexa you like
you don't like you don't have to like
you know just throw it out in the
fucking garbage yes I don't have one but
it all that stuff is it's interesting
you hear you talk about it because I
haven't thought about it fully and that
framing but I have thought about even
looking at the character I play and the
character in the show and kind of
something we talked about a lot as we're
crafting the show up until this point we
don't really call him an addict in the
show yet because I don't think you know
you are for a while right I don't think
you know what's happening for a while
and it's self diagnosed so I can't call
it that either right no no but it's it's
it is like it is that is what's
happening you know on a level but we've
come on however most addicts don't go
around me like help me stop being an
addict yeah yeah so that's why I would
even know but even like someone calling
that out or yeah yet I mean just um
we're kind of trying to yeah build it in
and have it kind of like creep in
because I think that's how someone comes
to their sense it's not right away it
takes a while and and so much of it has
been trying to kind of have like yeah
we're getting pacing of that and yet I
don't it's interesting because I never I
mean I haven't at this point thought of
him
as that in the show that's how I view
myself but yeah going like oh this
person's life is becoming unmanageable
and it's looking for a power greater
than himself to restore himself pity
which is what we do so I see it very
much through that lens of like you know
but I think you're I think you're on to
it yeah I think I'm hired I think you're
but I do but that to me is like that is
it's just such a parent to watch like
because you know it's people are so
afraid of showing that they're not in
control of something like the episode
not to spoil but there's you know an
episode where your sister character gets
a scholarship to law school and you're
going to watch it anyway and enjoy it
and the whole show being about like
being humble yeah and in the Muslim
culture can you just well she she kind
of goes down this spiral and it's this
interesting thing of like and I think
this is in a lot of cultures again one
of those things were you put it out and
then someone's like dude this is like
Greek people this is like yeah you know
I mean we ain't even for us growing up I
think like the most Arab movie we we
watched was My Big Fat Greek Wedding my
guys like my whole family was like yeah
that's my that's my aunt whatever but
kind of going down this rabbit hole of
yeah her feeling like oh man I put
something out that I would like to talk
about something and then feeling she
talks about like the evil eye kind of
coming to culturally and kind of like
feeling that and being put on her her
whole family telling her she has to be
humble has to be humble has to think
this certain way has to not show
anything because of jealousy because of
all these other energies and so we kind
of get into this rabbit hole of how you
can consume yourself with what you think
other people think of you and how so
much of not protecting your energy it's
not even so much that a curse is being
put on you but you are so vulnerable to
anything that anyone says anyone does
that you lose your own boundaries of who
you are your own boundaries of yourself
and we kind of watch her go down this
rabbit hole which was really fun to make
I mean and Mae Cal Maui who plays my
sister it was based on real stuff for
her
he was really going through like that
but even the stuff in the in the episode
you know it's yeah she kind of like she
you know not to give it away but like
the what she's going through when she's
experiencing is real yeah yes yes yes
and no but I just think in where I come
from it's the opposite it's you bloviate
and lie and pretend you have more going
on than you actually have going on so it
was just like really interesting to
watch that just the idea of humility is
not something I surprise surprise um in
my podcast I do my house it was so
interesting to watch just the idea of
you know how we're navigating like shame
around being successful shame around not
being successful enough and I just wanna
be like we're all just in this like
finger job you know of a nightmare and
and then I was I was thinking about to
me actually one of the craziest things
that happened in the show for me one of
the most like shocking things that I saw
in the show I almost want you to guess
but I don't think II well I don't know
if I will unless it's not Atlantic City
it might be something no I literally
more shocking to me than an Atlantic
City I was like like it made me gasp uh
was when Marshall uh said I don't know
oh yeah yeah yeah I was like like the
idea of incredibly wise person the
epitome of wisdom is saying I don't know
yeah and then the second most shocking
thing was you saying
after you your character excuse me had
fucked up you said I was just trying to
make you like me yeah and I remember
going that is the most disgusting thing
I can think of to say yeah yeah needing
saying as someone who lives for other
like that is the most vulnerable I hate
the word brave because it always like
describes women that don't wear makeup
on camera yeah but like it's so we've
lost about its that is the most
courageous thing you can say is like I
was trying to make you like me yeah yeah
like is that something that you got that
like I would never occur to me to even
like have a character say that well it's
because it's just so it's like
so much of the choice with the character
for me in order to stop myself from
being a full sociopath in making a show
called Rami like I'm not trying to make
a show with my name where this dude's
just like Oh Maurice does like walks
into Starbucks and they know it's order
which girl to marry and it's like oh man
like you know I want I want him to get
into something that can be useful that
can be that can be stirring that can be
like speaking of something that I think
like I said anything we're trying to
hide so he's very he leaves with his ego
this is an ego this is a very
stripped-down ego version I think a lot
of times in my life I've been I like
just endlessly love my family and
they've been really good you know
barometers for me on how to be a person
and I feel like there been a lot of
times where you know you're at a fork
and just because it may be someone said
the right thing you you went right
instead of going left and and then
there's times you did go left and you
did and you went the wrong way whatever
it might be but I wanted to design a
character that like really goes left
more than he goes right like he really
does take the wrong fork and like I
really wanted it to be that version of
myself that version of anyone where
there's sometimes this like alternate
timeline you can look out of yourself
and be like man I could have been that
guy and sometimes you're like man I
could have been the better version of me
you know and and you you find yourself
on the wrong one and and and we're the
one that doesn't feel the most you right
even removing right from wrong it's like
if we're all just trying to live up to
our potential we do so many things that
take us away from that you know grossest
things I've done are under the guise of
trying to make someone like me the irony
of when you're trying to make someone
like you you do the most unlikable
things like like the smallest most
granular like to get granular about it
is like when you're like you know you're
20 minutes when you look I'm five
minutes away yeah yeah to try to get you
to feel good I'm gonna lie to you and
waste your time and be 15 minutes late
it's just like it is the most
see moronic thing you can do and the
most it's insanity I think I have to
confront you on something
oh just the green shake you just took a
sip up okay so I was I was I was going
and I said you know on my way I'm like
hey I'm gonna stop by because I know you
like the cafe and I'm like I'm gonna get
you you know and you said I'll venmo you
like I'm and I it actually insulted me
because like you're like you're gonna
venmo me for a shake like woah did you
genuinely want to venmo me the amount or
was that just like you being nice like
what was that mean read you these texts
that rot me nice this is the most dry
drunk shit I've done in a while the most
shit venmo you these shakes by the way
the shake that I haven't been drinking
because I took a sip and it was like an
ASMR nightmare like it sounded so loud
when I took a sip so it's just like over
here chilly I'm gonna drink more I I
just want to make sure okay so on his
way you were gonna stop at a restaurant
good smoothie I just wanna make sure you
you were stopping for yourself right
right but I know you were saying I know
you like it this is the I care see you
were stopping anyway well this is what I
said to you I said hey I'm either gonna
stop here I'm gonna go through your
fridge like those so I was being honest
I was like I'm hungry
yeah it's my way of saying so I'm either
gonna stop there and get you something
cuz I know you like it but I'm gonna eat
or I'm gonna come in your house and eat
something at your house so that was the
the 4k and then I and you through venmo
in there I don't like I said get my
fridge is a mess yes and then I said
literally whatever you want and then I
kind of like made a Joe stop if your
heart is taking you there and I'll take
something if you do right like it was
only if you're starving anyway good the
idea of you stopping to grab me a
smoothie he's like horrifying to you yet
I was physically ill I was shaking like
I was it was we're good totally
traumatizing we're good to there and
then does Benton with any asked to give
us an invention and I'm like okay now
he's just the best
well I've been to any time I've come
here Benton's here so I was get some for
Benton and then yes and then I said all
venmo yo which was me totally going like
what that was why like that was insane
like I was like what and part of that is
like an Arab culture thing where I'm
like you know I'm buying you like a
smoothie like and it's so frustrating to
me anytime someone who I feel like
because it's like it goes back to the
question if you ask me like are we
friends and I'm like yeah this was like
how dare
like it's so it's so wild you're like
understand like how like insulting that
is to be okay let me give you $11 so
there's nothing between us and it's like
what is the because I don't think you're
saying it because you think I don't have
you you know I have eleven here but but
it's more like I don't want you to think
that I'm an entitled bitch that just
like doesn't think about money and
doesn't you know what I mean like I
don't like owing people and I associate
love with scorekeeping or generosity
generosity makes I have to receive like
remember how hard it was for you to
receive the compliment of me saying um
the best closer I've heard in the last
10 years how uncomfortable you got oh no
I think I felt great I said I said
admittedly it's hard to take a
compliment but thank you you're talking
about sounds like an intimacy issue like
if I'm being honest it's sad and I'm not
trying to accuse I'm not trying to like
put down any sort of that decision I'm
just saying now that we've been here for
an hour me not trust men can't imagine
why yeah I I just I never I think it
also this and since we're not dating or
anything it's even weirder that I did
that oh that you did that were like
platonic friends and I did that that
makes it even dumber and I know this is
worse I know you have money like it's
just like the whole thing is disgusting
I'm pushing you away
I think we're getting too close and I'm
getting scared so I have to hurt you or
whatever that was I was so funny it has
to be and then gifts for you by the way
I'm like I can't receive anything from
you but here's to back in a candle and
like and all that like this is amazing
you so many presents but I wouldn't let
you get this many wild I want all the
listeners to know that Benton ray just
attacked me for being authentic and for
being truthful and we you know this
about me I use the products that sponsor
this podcast and Benton just tried to
shame me for it
well we have more than that one product
I got the ever lane brown tawny
butterscotchy shirt that I love so much
I talk about it every time we do an ad
and he's like talk about something else
besides that brown shirt you talk about
all that all the time was I mean it got
a good shirt we get it it's soft its
classic looks like you graduated from
Yale we got it it's such a good color
I'm on their Instagram right now and I
love these like Browns I'm very into
their call it the Everleigh does these
they do basics with these really fresh
earth tones earth totally what it is
that I love you know a Virgo loves her
earth tones so this is what I love okay
they tell you the real costs and they're
radically transparent about every step
in the process so normally when you go
buy clothes you're paying for the model
they hire the actress they hire the
billboards the magazine's this it with
every Lane you don't pay for any of that
stuff no matter your style or preference
ever Elaine's clothes look better they
cost less they last longer because every
Lane sells directly to you their prices
are 30 to 50% lower than traditional
retail so you're not paying for that
real estate in the mall for them to have
a store just goes directly to you it's
the future or is it the present
cotton crew t-shirt exactly what it
should be versatile simple stylish made
from quality materials right now you can
check out our personalized collection at
everland comm slash Whitney plus you'll
get free shipping on your first order if
you want to look like me get the brown
shirt and cry a lot that's ever lame
dot-com slash Whitney ever Lane comm
slash Whitney what's the most important
thing to me Benton napping sleeping yeah
you love you love to tell me I'm taking
a nap from 4:00 to 5:00 I'm taking a nap
from 1:00 to 2:00 nothing is more
important to me than my REM sleep
sleeping doesn't always mean REM sleep
you can be lying there and not actually
getting sleep and it has taken me it has
been a journey my insomnia journey has
been a long winding one and it took me a
long time to realize that my mattress is
the thing that I needed to figure out
like it just it drives me nuts that it
took me so long to figure out what
Matros to sleep on because i actually
like a firm mattress because otherwise I
get claustrophobic and I feel like I'm
in quicksand
and it activates my anxiety I actually
didn't know there was different types of
mattresses till we took this class I
just thought they were all the same
everybody sleeps differently you take a
quiz it takes like two minutes and it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress you
know how like sometimes like I used to
oh my god I sleep really good in that
one hotel but only because that's the
mattress that worked with my body right
mmm the fact that you expect everybody
to sleep on the same mattress is
ridiculous they have soft medium firm
mattresses that are great for cooling
you down that's the other thing because
I run hot at night it's what I got into
and I wake up in like a pool of sweat
this is you know I mean I have night
terrors that's a whole other thing
and helix has plus size mattresses
basically you take the quiz you're
matched with the mana what was I
you got the done dusk luxe mattress dusk
luck and sighing at the plus okay I
wanted something that felt like really
really firm and it's weird I used to
sleep on my side but now I sleep on my
back which I know is like yeah and they
ask you that question which I've never
even knew that was a matter you get a
different one if you sleep on your side
your back your stomach or if you move
around all night so you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to you can
add on the sheets or pillows whatever
else you need in your bed and then the
mattress comes right to your door within
10 business days he looks with awarded
the number one best overall mattress
place in 2020 by GQ and Wired magazine
helix is offering up to $200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep comm slash
Whitney but I think that for me for the
longest time as a female comic or just
before I was so trained to believe that
if a man pays for anything they're now
in control of you yeah our power and I
think I also watched the generation of
women before me at least in that I saw
in America like it was very much you
know I I'm Pro gold digger like that's
all that's the only option that really
was until like 30 years ago like we just
started calling them gold diggers you
know like what option did they have
like men took all the gold so like what
else were women gonna do go like you
know make 20 cents being a secretary and
like who was you know so like that was
the only option you really had was to
find a man that had resources and I'm
also kind of I know I'm saying this in
jest but I was like doing all this
research on like Palm Beach Florida gold
diggers like the women that married rich
men or whatever these women that married
these like huge business men and I'm
like if you can get a really successful
businessman to sign a shitty country I'd
like you're kind of a genius and they
have to hold these parties and I was
like reading about this one woman she's
like Lily something like a big socialite
and she has these big parties every
night and has to like carry on these
conversations for three hours and I'm
like they were like the first podcaster
yeah for years like they were doing this
you know like it's hard to talk for
three hours and and so I think for me I
had so much because I watched women
depend on men for everything financially
and otherwise that I think I
overcompensate the other way where I'm
like I always want to come off like
completely needless and independent yeah
so that there are no strings attached
because I assume everybody else is is
codependent as I am or more used to be
and like keep score of everything
because everything came with a price
like all the generosity I had a kid came
with a price on me - yeah there was a
but I got you that smoothie three months
ago yeah yeah like that there was like
okay now you have like something in your
arsenal to throw at me of course yeah
and and and this is the thing this is
the thing to note with intimacy issues
is that I have them you have them
whatever um it might you might not be
the reason why you have them yeah I mean
you just listed a lot of really valid
things and so even for the accusation to
be leveraged against you that you have
intimacy issues is it's almost kind of
like reductive because it's very
reductive because it's it makes it seem
like it's uniquely yours that's right
and so it's it's it should almost make
you feel better where it's like well
yeah but like that's not just yeah yeah
yeah that's even the start was my
therapist always like given the
circumstances how else what were you
what else would you do in what world
would you have any other ideas how like
well how would you
how to do anything besides that yes if
someone says that to you and it's like
okay yeah and like then so like okay you
to like circumstances this makes perfect
sense yeah duh and I think that it's
interesting because to the same point
about earlier of like how you know
trying to control the way you're
embarrassed I think you know for me once
you get emotionally attached to someone
it's like the Damocles sword is hung you
know and it then becomes about waiting
for the other shoe to drop but it's
you're giving someone else power over
you you're giving someone the power to
hurt you at any moment yeah you're
giving someone the ability to hurt you
at any moment yeah because we're
constantly trying to figure out a way to
not get hurt yeah that's get scary
really important like who who's allowed
into those spaces so it's like there's
nothing wrong with having walls long as
you know why they're there and you put
them up they should be boundaries maybe
not well cuz boundaries make our
intimacy it's this is all the coin
therapy stuff I do like boundaries make
you more capable of intimacy there
between intimacy and entrenchment yeah
right there's an eye entrench
yeah and that's been really historically
unhealthy so I'm always trying to figure
out what's the difference between
codependents and intimacy mmm because I
conflate them all the time
right because they wanting someone not
needing someone knowing when you end and
they begin you know like my therapist
always says that if you hold sand in
your hand like this you can hold it
forever but if you hold it like this
you'll lose it oh that's cool you know
and two trains if they're going next to
each other they can go forever but if
they go like this they're gonna crash oh
so intimacy is that do you another one
yeah any more hand gestures just kinda
there like analogy hi no those are two
good well I was like kind of thought
there'd be a third like a close the
comedy brain I'm like a lot of things do
you it's good but you know so it's like
it's not about it's about not stand is
that's brilliant I've never heard that
that's because we want to do this in
relationships but this is how you can do
it forever
and mine where I am such an entrench or
you know and I am such a like I can feel
rejected when I'm in the same room with
somebody and what I in my tolerance is
so high for adrenaline cortisol oxytocin
it's just like what we say and you know
program one too many a million not
enough you know it's just sort of
like it I'm insatiable and and I think a
lot of what the program is is about
making yourself satiable mmm and about
being able to moderate yeah you know and
being able to put boundaries up that
aren't like walls they're not defensive
they're just protective of everybody
yeah I really yeah your walls is is a
slur for sure
yeah walls is like boundaries is totally
bad has such a negative connotation yeah
like that's me and walls feel permanent
I think that's what it is me or yes
they've been there before you and there
you know boundaries benefit everyone yes
and you know Georgia my therapist who's
been on the show we talk a lot about how
important words are because like I
always say like oh this isn't healthy
like this not healthy I'm doing this I'm
not allowed to say that I have to say
it's not helpful I can't say it's not
healthy like you can't pathologize
yourself like there's a lot of like so I
like you did that like boundaries and
walls because that's the thing with with
the echoing therapy stuff that I do that
yeah you to come see at some point
because what you realize is that the
closer you get you're gonna get hurt
yeah you know so drawing a boundary is
actually how you guys are able to not
hurt each other you know to keep a
little bit of distance so I'm always
trying to figure out the difference
between that I love yeah I love that you
just the the the the relationship with
animals and like really getting I do
want to come because I don't have I'm so
I feel so disconnected from nature
sometimes like I think part of it's just
the way I just feel like I grew up
hardwired to the internet and and just
hardwired to having a computer like I
had one in my room when I was 10 or is
it like when I think about my natural
habitat it's like that LED light and
like I just like like like it's so it's
so I part of what I've loved in this
part of my life is kind of being like
yeah I really need to go on I need to be
outdoors I like wanna do like it's like
it's such it's so important that but I
lose sight of it I mean but it's truly
like you know you don't make as much
serotonin like I mean like it's I mean
it's like the most I mean I moved out
here into the woods or whatever and I
was like oh I'm not as crazy as I
thought I just needed to like be like
see it's pattern-recognition also you
know I also grew up
sort of in parts of Virginia but it's
also like we're designed to see in
surveil large spaces like if you're not
able to see in your peripheral vision
we're just like have more isn't it funny
how like if you get thirty minutes
outside of any major city it feels like
parts of Virginia yes yes visually and
politically yes but it's also it's like
we still in our primordial brains when
you're in an apartment or a place alone
on you know a primordial level we
believe we've been exiled from the tribe
and don't have the protection the tribe
like we need to be around people have
you read tribe huh Sebastian Junger oh
yes of course I don't know I I read a
couple years ago I don't know about the
doc game I got them behind but did you
ever see his appearance on the show the
affair no fucked up my whole different
tangent about that later so funny for
something to be so tangential it's not
podcast where I'm like I'm almost like
this probably gonna be a complete waste
of time
whoa this is like a off tangent and we
have food yeah no but I I think that
that's like you know it's so important
also I think to me it's like for you and
because to me God is is is everyone has
different definitions like I don't want
to put my definition anyone but for me
it's like we say God is in the pauses
like that's what we say in in program is
God is in the pause and the ability to
take a contrary action and not act on
your like react to be able to make it
like conscious decision it's like God is
like it's like you have the most
brilliant joke in your special about
wearing condoms I don't want to blow the
joke but it's like how you feel Monday
right yeah it's it's like that's like
such a brilliant insight and to me God
is very much how I feel when I have made
the right decision afterwards or have
made the decision with integrity yeah in
the pride I feel afterwards opposed to
the shame so just the ability to stop
and not act on my like primordial like
you know instincts and so that I can
feel pride afterwards and the deal is
with working with animals is they don't
have shame they don't care what you
think of them they don't I mean it's
like you said in the show of like be
more like this
it's like being around animals because
we don't the thing that they don't have
that we have is the ability to
manipulate people with our verbal
communication right and to trigger
people into whatever like we're all just
in our trauma responses all the time and
being around animals you're actually
able to be authentic and not be
performing or worried about what someone
thinks of you cuz we're always changing
based on who or with whether we want to
admit it or not like something's
happening and your egos involved somehow
but when you're around animals you
really see your ego come up because you
can't control them they're sure you
can't impress them you can't they don't
care about your Golden Globe they don't
care about your fancy special they don't
care about all the awards you want and
you're it's just you and them and you're
like oh shit like my energy is the only
thing that I can offer you because with
horses the only reward for them because
that make grace they don't care they're
not they're not they don't need they
Grace and get grass the only thing that
they need from you is tranquility in the
in leadership and they'll tell you right
away with their energy like they'll just
like if you need anything from them that
translates to fear animals so if you're
going to come in with like I need to get
a picture with you I need you to like me
or I want to pet you they're just like
want to get away from you because in
their brain they're like oh there's a
mountain lion close by this person's
stressed out they just want to get away
from you like they have no interest
they've no motive if they haven't been
wired to serve and read faces the same
way that dogs have yeah you know so they
really show you who you are and we
really messed up dogs I mean that I I
know we I think we would get into a
debate on the town but I really think
we're iured dogs into into some we're
into a weird into a weird corner we're
now the only logical thing to do is take
care of them yeah you know I mean the
only logical thing to do is to adopt as
many as we can
mm-hmm I've gone down some rabbit holes
though of I think there were these VIP
euerle focused on dogs rights I know
that they were really into animal rights
PETA like is this couple out of a couple
like professor I think they're at
Rutgers but you know don't quote me ever
on anything that's a podcast don't quote
me on anything ever
only semblance of what I'm talking about
but they had kind of I remember reading
this argument wherever it might have
been where they basically said the most
ethical thing we can do for dogs right
now is neuter every dog that you can see
and take care of the ones who are cats
yeah let's just just new to them and
love and provide for and give the most
organic amazing you know home that you
can and if any survived that means
they're surviving in the wild and those
are the breeds that should be allowed to
run wild and and basically what we're
doing is this massive emotional you know
servitude and and and and there's a it's
it's it's fascinating when you think
about it because it's like and this is
something you talk about my special but
sometimes I have crossed over but it's
just because it's all stuff I care about
like yeah the whole thing but it's like
this thing of like oh I'm telling this
creature
you know when they can do all these
things they're not near their tribe
they're not read their family and it's
super remote it's it's emotional yeah
wild it's it's like and I don't know the
right answer I grew up with a dog I want
one right I know what's going I won't
Anthony Jeselnik came in here without a
dog now he has a dog I I saw like the I
feels what I do well you know I'm like
floating right now as to where I'm
living now I'm just giving up the place
I have in New York I feel like once I
have a home I will rescue a dog but man
it's complicated it's really complicated
I mean even and even what you're saying
about horses and then not being you know
programmed in the in the in the way that
it's really interesting to me I just I
well I really do want to know more about
it I don't I like it it makes me want to
connect in that way because and we've
talked about this too even in like
talking about therapy and stuff we're
talking about like Grinberg method and
all that yeah I like moments and I like
things where words are not an option
what we do it's so cool I know how to
yeah I know how to you but I'll I know
the right word yeah well my whole our
whole study is like yep I can inflict
something a certain way and I'll pick
this word instead of that word and it's
gonna create an emotion but like where
are you really truly disarmed that's
exciting to me that's what's so cool
like that's yeah it's really fun it's I
mean and that's that's it's really all
non
communication like with horses and it's
um it's it's stressful it's also you
know I was you know is it please
obviously correct me if I'm wrong is the
does Islam mean to submit is that right
would it and that when I was like
reading about it this week I was like oh
my god that is what in a way the best
version of of any way of life is like me
is about and that's what 12-step
programs would surrender right same
thing and that's what at coin therapy is
because it's not I can't control a horse
it's stronger than me if I can break its
spirit and turn into a carriage horse
and that's what most people do
racehorses and some horses don't want to
do any of that if you decide you're
going to treat a prey animal with
integrity you have to submit to that
animal in earnest respect so that's
really what it's about it's about the
patience and submitting to like I'm not
gonna get what I want from you today I
now have to examine why I won in the
first place is it ego is it it's less
even like so like assignments submitting
it's not necessarily that you're
submitting to the horse you're
submitting to what that moment is
actually supposed to be right so it's
like there's a certain harmony and it's
like like we're constantly just trying
to I always think like we're trying to
be on beat like it's just there's
wherever we are there's something
happening we're trying to we're trying
to clap like just on the right on the
right beat but that's not to say any
environment you go into you should do
that like you should really only clap if
your integrity is in that mm-hmm
whatever that rhythm might be whatever
that song might be wherever it is that
you're at so that's why it's super
important to be in the right
environments because wherever you are
you're gonna try and align you're gonna
try and be with that rhythm wherever you
are so it's really important to know
where you are it's really that's what
we're talking about boundaries that's
you just being like well I'm not gonna
clap to this cuz this isn't that's not
my jam that's not my song that's not
what I'm supposed to be doing and so
it's really like when we talk about God
talked about it's really recognizing how
small you are and how how sensitive all
this is and you say gods in the pauses
it's very it's it's to me it feels like
so many of the things that I think about
which is I want a life that's integrated
we're like I am really feeling like I'm
living by my principle
I'm really feeling like I'm living by
what feels right and and you don't have
those like moments of oh man I gave in
to my carnal desire yeah I did this I
just started I just started clapping I
started joining just because it was what
was you know we haven't all it happens
to us it happens to the best people it
has you know so it's no one's immune to
following that but yeah we're constantly
trying to be integrated into a place
where yeah where we can live and
integrity and do that and and so yeah I
mean and I bring up all the music stuff
to to pitch this musical that I'm
writing would you like it that's at like
I in the middle of talking I was like
this sounds like how Lynn is gonna
introduce his next thing and I'm like I
mean you that I just think is important
to bring up and I know your blood sugar
is probably plummeting since 1988 eight
countries have had Muslim women as their
heads of state including Turkey
Indonesia Senegal Kosovo Bangladesh two
different women Pakistan and Mauritius
many Muslim countries including
Afghanistan Iraq Pakistan and Saudi
Arabia have a higher percentage of women
in national elected office than does the
United States yeah what do I do with
this information I mean I know more
people know that yeah it's it's
something that we haven't had a female
president yet mm-hmm and we're not going
to for a minimum of four years mm-hmm
it's wild it's I mean I'm sorry it's
like everything you think you know is
not it's just not what you think it is
yeah so it yeah I I brought that up so
many times and I'm like what is everyone
talking about yeah you know like what do
you
yeah like actually look at the fat you
know it's it's well yeah no I think I
mean I've seen the show you do I think
such an amazing job of critiquing the
parts of you know the older generations
the way that you know women are seen and
then you look at it and you're like oh I
have an uncle that talks like that and
he's Catholic okay I'm gonna ask you a
couple things before I release you I
could do this with you forever but I
don't want to ruin our friendship I'm
just a couple of random questions I
always ask on the show which is and I
can name some if you want some time to
think what is a red flag in a person a
possible new friend or romantic
conquests good red-flag where we talk
about red flags on the show
besides the venmo thing ok so let me ask
you question if we go to dinner yeah
we're both gonna try to pay sure and
then one of us does and I'm an alumna
and I should don't want to lose well I
don't know that depends on cuz I got
this one you get the next one that's
kind of how we don't keep score and now
keep score and it's also yeah it's also
it's just kind of organic back to you to
pay me for the gifts I gave you are you
not gonna want to go on there I have so
much shit around money so much
complicated nasty shit yeah I never and
cuz I also never I think when I first
started making money I would go out to
noon with my friends and the bill will
come and they people will be on the
phones I'm like oh I'm okay I'm covering
that like yeah yeah I grew up without
money so now okay I'm the person you
know what I mean and I remember when I
was poor and I couldn't pay the bill and
I didn't want anyone and I pretended I
had money when I didn't for years when I
have like $20 in my bank account I was
like what if someone at this tables in
that position I don't want them to I'll
just get it so no one even has talked
this is another American thing those who
there's a lot of weirdness around money
the in this country not having money and
then getting money is intrinsically
linked to the idea of what it means to
be an American and so it's like it's
this weird thing where it's like if if
you're born into money it's almost like
how dare you you didn't do the verb of
America like like the verb of being an
American is I made money like I didn't
and then I did it is that that idea of
like you know that's the American dream
yeah it's it's the pursuit of happiness
it's all those things and so when people
don't see you do that pursuit or if
people feel like your pursuit was not
worthy of the amount of money you got
rights too and you know easy it's like
well you just stole it you or or let you
you you you you stole it because all you
did was tell some jokes or oh well if I
grew up in your situation I would have
been able to do that or oh well if I
looked like you I'd be able
oh if whatever and not only is that
lever II don't deserve you you don't
deserve it I mean and it's leveraged
towards you but then it's also like
because you also grew up here you kind
of believe it about yourself you kind of
think about yourself like the imposter
syndrome like how did I what am I doing
here and it's such a such a useless
place to live when you actually have
money because there's so much you could
do with that money
yeah that is only going to help people
and that is going to give you kind of a
lot of the things that you know you want
and and and it money can I think be used
in a way of like elevated selfishness
like we're all selfish right we're all
we're all doing I offered them out of
now that we got these but we're all so
we're all kind of like choosing the
nuance of like what kind of selfish do I
want to be yeah am I gonna be the kind
of selfish who you know cuts people off
in traffic because I want to get
somewhere sooner and does all these
things am I the kind of selfish that is
gonna go to like a soup kitchen because
that's I'm I want to fulfill helping
other people that's good that's healthy
yeah that's a healthy selfish that's
really healthy addictions like you know
such a thing as healthy addictions
healthy and it's good and and and and
there's actually this is really great
Jesuit priest this dude Anthony de Mello
he wrote this book called awareness he
talks a lot about healthy like elevated
selfishness and it
I remember reading it and it's amazing
because it just shows you like your
willpower and kind of like where you can
be at and what you can do with all that
so anyway I say they stay like that the
money stuff is so tied to America and
kind of how we view our value and I
think when people are railing against
capitalism I think they're talking about
the emotional elements of it too they're
talking about how enslaved we are to
what is in our bank account not just
because it's there but because of what
it does to our mental state and our
self-worth you know so it's less it's
it's part of it is yeah being able to
buy that smoothie the other part of is
is you know how I view my self-image and
I it is so interesting that I have so
much shame because yeah you have I ever
had shame when I didn't have money and
I've shame now that I can't pay my bills
yeah and I never and it is so weird how
insulting it
you realize like helping is never
helping people pleasing as a form of
asshole early like the whole corner
starter of codependence of the I just
wanted you to like me so I was a
complete asshole
but the no but let me pay for it's just
it's such a it's such a fucking gross
it's like and you know what else it does
it's patronizing it's like you don't
really want to be doing what you're
doing yeah yeah yeah I'm accusing you of
being an undercover codependent by I I'm
going oh well he's only going cuz he
thinks I want like I've I've
pathologized you by doing that yeah yeah
no it does it creates this whole thing
that's not that's not that's not the red
flag though so the red flag the red flag
for me maybe might be in a new anything
yeah if I feel like the majority look
I'm we're comics there's always a level
of shit talking but if I feel like the
majority of how someone wants to bond
with me is by kind of beating down on
someone else or something else I'm kind
of bored I'm just bored and I tend to be
bored more than offended on most things
Wow because I'm kind of like oh I mean
it's not like someone was doing it to me
I mean even if somebody like robbed my
house I'm not like ended you know I mean
like if someone says something bad about
me like sure it could hurt my feelings
but to be offended would be to take it
so personally no point like this is so
much bigger than me like yeah it isn't
about me it's not about it's not really
it's about so many other thing what kind
of narcissist thinks someone robbing
your house is about you shit talking you
though yeah so much for talking my work
I'm like some of it could maybe be a
little bit about me but it's not really
about it's so much bigger it's about
it's the thing it touched on for you is
the type of mirror put on or maybe you
don't like the a song choice is that
whatever whatever that might be
Wow that Israel so for me like I just
tend to be kind of like if I'm really
taking my time to be with someone on any
level I just get bored if the majority
of what we're doing is you're just
talking about somebody else you know and
and it's just very unattractive only mmm
yeah negativity complaining also like
trauma bonding in general is a false
sense of bonding you know yeah I mean I
think like
you know I think if you've been through
similar things it I think it'd give you
a false sense of intimacy it could it
could be the beginning of some bonding
it could be something but it but it's
got to grow out of that
is it otherwise the the friendship
whatever it might be
becomes a very quickly becomes a space
where it's for that that's right because
and you know it like you look back at
friends sometimes like oh that's my shit
talking a friend like like your best
friend yeah I got a couple chains
certain things like whatever the best
friendships the most exciting ones are
the ones where I'm like oh we're gonna
meet up and I don't know what's gonna
happen yeah I'm not sure yeah this one
comic maybe for a sec but it also could
go many other ways like that's what's
exciting in me is like feeling like
there's like genuine curiosity of what
could happen hmm
because I I realize it taking me so long
that to realize that in so many
relationships I I try very hard
we call it restraint and pen and tongue
like wait to tell your traumatic things
horrible thing don't talk about that for
awhile friendships relation of anything
because then it's gonna be a dynamic of
either it's gonna it's gonna start to be
someone's gonna be the maternal one
someone's gonna be the problem solve or
someone's gonna be like the mentor
someone's gonna have done more work than
the other person's gonna be like the
sponsor or whatever and someone's gonna
be the sponsee and then that's the
dynamic so it's like every time you hang
out it's like like I'm realizing that I
have cultivated this environment where
people come to me like for advice all
the time yeah and it's given me this
false sense of thinking I figured things
out when fucked-up people ask you for
advice that doesn't mean you are healed
when crazy people think you're saying
that doesn't make you sane and I've been
like cast in this thing ride this false
sense of emotional progress because
truly batshit people thought I was
together them thinking I'm together
doesn't mean I'm like a naked person
asking you for fashion and yeah well
they don't yes it's like of course they
love your work in any way like the bar
is so low so and also I've spent a lot
of time conflating love and pity yeah
and I'm not knowing the difference and
also being perfectly happy receiving
pity in lieu of love it's a great great
novel poem name by the way conflating
love not
my next letting love conflating love and
pity is so Elizabethan but it's a
motherfucker yeah it's nice it's hard to
tell the difference sometimes and I used
to lead with all my trauma because then
either it would I'd feel like the risk
of abandonment was lower yeah because
the person wouldn't leave someone who's
been traumatized I mean you know I mean
like you I guilt
I'll take guilt yeah if that's what it
takes to keep you or something or I'll
take pity because I don't think I'm
enough without my trauma I don't think
I'm interesting enough I don't think I'm
worthy enough for you to stay because my
trauma is what's attractive about me or
something or interesting or that like
you need some kind of tether you know
yeah real fun dude yeah I don't want you
I'm too scared for you to have to like
choose to be with me every day I want
you to have some kind of codependent Ted
that like hook I need to put like a hook
in you I didn't realize that's what I
was subconsciously doing and I think
also as a kid being sick or something
that's how I got attention as a kid
that's the only time you can really
break through and get attention and now
call it home is when you're hurt injured
sick something so then you're like oh
that's the thing that's compelling about
me is why I'm injured in some way like
being whole is just is just like
repellents you know and then you start
vibrating really unhealthy sick people
that want to like rescue a wounded bird
and then you feel like stay wounded so
that it's just like a whole hashtag it's
pain Canyon um one more thing I'm gonna
ask you you know it's funny so much of
your show is about overcoming temptation
yeah to me yeah again it's my show now
no it's whoever's shows watch it at this
point looks good and I was just thinking
about how when we do work about like my
biggest nightmare is asking people to do
things for me sure favors or feeling
like I owe someone and then I started a
podcast and now that's all I do yeah I
know I remember you were like dude this
is my biggest nightmare asking you to do
it the fact you're here I'm fear like
it's a this is a night I'm been mowing I
like I would have been you mow you for
your time I feel like I and then I was
like and I was talking to dr. Shepherd
about I was like why did I the my heart
I signed up to for eternity do the thing
that every week I have to do the thing
that is various to me
which is ask someone to do something and
not question their motives or think that
they're doing it out of guilt or
whatever I feel like you getting so
successful and so famous must make it so
there's so many more temptation yeah you
know there's something so interesting
about creating the very thing that we're
all trying to overcome yeah and almost
exacerbating it with trying to solve it
yeah you know it's weird it's it's
definitely it puts you in a situation
again like kinda we were saying earlier
where you you you see how people can get
tricked into feeling like oh I'm just a
master of like everything that I that
I'm doing and and we feel we're almost
assured to feeling like the word creator
you know but you're a content creator
you're a creator like it's so it has it
has such biblical implications like it's
like landlord yeah it feels so like
there's all this stuff and and I'm not
even I'm not even like saying it's a
terrible word or something but it you
just start getting in that situation I
just like you took a picture of your ass
yeah she created this montage of it in
seven days and seven nights in Sigerson
on the seventh day she rested on her
thong or whatever you know and like I'm
not but this is a critique of Instagram
models I actually think you know I could
I could argue the only fans is like
maybe one of the more feminist things
happening but it for me the things that
I'm excited about doing and I want to do
and like the places that excite me
creatively it'd be really hard for me to
feel too big in those places they make
me feel the right kind of small they
make me feel like what I the way I want
to feel and then and there's something
about things being more available to you
where they start to feel less
interesting hmm I think a lot of the
time things feel way more interesting
when you think you can't have them
and so I really I have felt that human
nature's a motherfucker huh dude we're
wild it's somebody we're not to be
trusted
why would you trust any of us this is
not don't trust me act of getting
something you want makes you want it
less so yeah it's that guy but it's the
whole thing's faulty it's that and
that's a part of the reason I love most
prey animals it's all just about energy
conservation like their life is so
simple because they basically just
because of the limited amount of food
and the amount of muscle they have it's
really just about what is the most
economical choice yeah and their life is
so much simple it's simpler that way
we're like I got this thing I've been
chasing now I don't want anymore now I
need something else like it makes me
know that yeah like as soon as we got
opposable thumbs we just like got wild
you can I'm saying like it's just I
don't know just why we have to merge
with robots like this can't be a
simulant do you guys are you in the
simulation argument no this is just like
no okay I don't totally believe me it's
you've clearly had this fight before
with the money it matters only that just
we do want to know what we're playing on
a level so it it doesn't matter and it
does yeah that's kind of like most
things yeah to me that's like people who
have been podcasting for too long and
have run out of things to talk about so
are we in a simulation I think you know
I take a week off no I take a week off
like maybe just like take a month off of
every movie has a third act in every
podcast has its are we you know that's
you have to get to that place what's
your perfect day I asked for an
armistice and it was like such a good
answer and I just I haven't asked anyone
else that I'm just curious thanks for
telling me the historical precedent that
I should match and the crazy thing is I
don't even know what Fred's answer was
that's the crazy part so it's not even
like you're like well Fred said that
it's like the audience it's just like
live
see if you'd be more of your the only
person who I thought could maybe step
into these shoes I don't know I'm not
secure because it's such a bad question
like it's like you said a bad question
you're like but you know this isn't on
me because someone did answer well yeah
someone did so let's see if you get best
of luck solve my problem
no I remember because there was
something really sad about it because he
he was just like like just doing
something work-related and going home
and that's pretty much it like it was
such a simple answer right and I was
really just inspired by it and you
strike me as the kind of person who
appreciates simple how complicated is to
just be simple yeah I'm learning that
but I'm also like I'm like mid
processing kind of I feel like I'm going
through understanding like a different
stage of life for a lot of reasons some
of it is a lot of it is purely just in
the age stage thing where you kind of
get to that place where you're like oh
no this is my like I'm not it starts to
feel less and less like when I grow up
like oh this is I'm better I've I'm up
that's the kind of you know so I'm kind
of in this thing where I don't think I
know the answer I'm trying to figure out
what the right day looks like because
I'm still shedding some some patterns of
not taking certain levels of
responsibility or some patterns of like
not again kind of talking about living
in an actual integrated way where where
I'm at constant living consciously with
my awareness like where I'm actually
tying what I believe and what I actually
do and and you know obviously like a
bunch of the show like I said is the gap
between those things but um
also even in making the show I'm like
well I need to be significantly more
integrated than than fictional me you
know so a lot of that is so many of the
things I do as fictional me is like to
make sure that I never become that you
know and so I try to almost challenge
myself you know to not to
Manifest any of that it's like an
exorcism I'm like let me get this out of
here I love your brain so much can I ask
you a question we can cut it out if you
want and you don't have to answer right
away I can by time do you have
oh I'm fascinated by you do you have a
working definition of the word love like
how do you know you're in love with
somebody you don't have to answer you
can think and I can tell you a couple I
heard one recently that I really liked
sure which was someone said I can be
really I've know I'm in love with
someone when I'm really mad at them but
still want the best for them mmm and I'd
like that
mm-hmm I like that I mean for me love
it's there's this at a certain point it
it's hard sometimes too and I think you
talk about this really well undoing love
from obligation undoing love from from
anything that you think you should be
doing mm-hmm you know and and really
looking at it and I found and this
speaks to all sorts of relationships I'm
feeling loved in relationships in my
life where I'm actually feeling like
were exchanging being fully ourselves
you know I actually feel it and I feel
anger and I feel happiness and I feel an
ability to like I really love being like
being able to say something and someone
like being able to take that feedback
and and and say something about it but
also like they get that it's they get
where it's coming from there's like a
shared language that's really important
for me it's really important for me to
be able to be like dude like that thing
you did I really didn't like that
because of this this and this uh-huh and
like to be able to go through that yeah
and still get dinner you know and then
like and then we're gonna go to dinner
we're gonna fight about who's paying for
dinner like it's like recover quickly
she's like how do we fight yes
that's the that's the best like love
like on on any level and when we're
fighting we'll be on the same team yeah
it's you know to the point of the fight
it's just a fight to destroy each other
or is this a fight to be like like
sometimes it's almost like like we're
we're like we're in a bunker I like you
I'm gonna fight you because like that
everything we don't want is coming for
us that's right can we prep ourselves so
we can be on the same page and like how
do we do that on are we able to do that
together and are we able to do that in a
real way but your ego has to be fucking
long gone in order to do that it's got
to be gone mm-hmm this was interesting
you mean creating an unlikable character
yeah it's funny like they're very fuckin
likable ah no no there are people who
don't like me in real life because of my
character on TV I like that that's
there's thing I know but I like that
you ready me go like like I that's
that's exciting to me because I'm like
oh cool there's nothing gay feels
something yeah I don't need to be
confused about any of it though so
someone does like me that means they
understand the medium of what it is that
I'm doing yeah and they also but it's
also like it doesn't mean anything it's
it's it doesn't mean anything on either
end right so I was like I know I created
a fictional thing that makes people hate
me in real life I'm like man this whole
medium of the emotions it creates is
flawed so even if someone is like in
pure adoration I'm like well that's a
flaw too like there's no like it's
review is if you believe the good you
don't like it doesn't really matter you
know so it stops it stops it doesn't
matter so it's it's it's just fun then
then it's just fun because then it's
just like well cool like let's just see
well let me press some buttons you know
like that's gonna be fun but also what
I'm hearing is like when you say you're
in relation when you're like I didn't
like that you did this for this this in
this reason yeah that already makes me
think you're that's my version of love
is not always like what are you doing
how are you making me feels how do I
feel when I'm with you if I feel
comfortable enough to say I'm
uncomfortable cuz yeah like I already
feel like there's love there yes because
I'm the best version of myself which is
someone who's being clear and standing
up for myself and not repressing
emotions or pretending yes yeah and and
I think and this is a may be a performer
specific thing but everyone really is
doing some sort of performance wearing
some sort of mask I mean the literally
wear masks
[Laughter]
the Long Beach Airport the the ability
to be with somebody where you're not
performing and you can feel it and
you're like I'm gonna be like I'm gonna
be kind of messy right now in front of
this person or like this person's
watching me lose my temper
anytime I'm like gonna you know get into
a place where I'm not gonna be as
composed as I usually am or I'm not
gonna like let it roll over me because
of the person I'm with I'm like that's a
good person I like that that loves you
or you love like you love it sounds so
corny and such like an Instagram thing
like it makes you like I wasn't with
someone once and it was like the hottest
thing anyone's ever said to me
I was started biking and like mountain
biking or whatever and look I've women
we have our body things I've had my body
things I won't speak for all women but
like the body dysmorphia thing I'm we're
getting out of the woods on it but I was
it's just like a habit my mom used to
say it she always used to touch her legs
and she touch her butt and she would say
you know I was just programmed to always
like think about your weight and I was
biking I was like oh I think this is
gonna make my thighs get bag yeah and he
just went was that bad and it was such
an amazing moment because I was like oh
my god and most of the really shows I've
ever been in it would be like you know
won't never like but would that like be
bad like it was just like this tiny
thing where it would have been such a
big deal to me before so it's also just
like the way someone makes you feel in
little moments like that yeah and that
don't the word trigger I can't believe
it hasn't come up yet but like someone
that doesn't just like trigger you by
accident even if it's not their fault
like there's some times where it's just
like this isn't your fault this is like
my programming in your programming or
just not aligning in a way that it's not
about me doing more work on myself for
being less sensitive because I will
shape-shift into whatever someone else
needs and I've done it before and I'm
finally at the place where I'm like you
know what I just don't I relationship
take work like totally got that but I
just like this isn't work I want to do
like I just want this to be easy and
simple I've done so much work on myself
like I finally like myself I also don't
want to get in something that's like oh
and here's all your homework to be in
this relationship well yeah that's now
right but I do think a lot of people
we'll get set off we get triggered in
relationships and it can be a really
good thing yeah because because you're
talking about like yes you've already
done the work and now you don't need to
like do it through the relationship but
I think for a lot of people the first
right relationship can be kind of like
yes
the real wake-up calls show me all the
ones that yeah yeah and then and then
it's like okay cool now that we've seen
this together hmm
are you still with me and like our but
and it's not like sit with me with my
wounds while I do nothing to them it's
almost like can we work on them together
because it's like it's always on both
ends and so yes it's the ability to like
I think it's it's all getting at the
same thing it's the ability to like work
through and fight through with integrity
you know and you're like oh wow I'm
doing this with someone and we're both
doing it with integrity yes that's what
we're like letting ourselves like get to
peak emotions it's awesome you mean like
because integrity doesn't mean being
quiet yeah it's like you could be wild
yeah that's when I know I really love
somebody like you know and it and it
goes in both ways we can be ecstatic
with each other yeah he be angry but
it's like it's never if the other person
is expensed yeah it's not it's not this
is I'm not doing this to dominate you
I'm doing this because it's in me and
I'm showing you or you're doing these
rumors about me internalize them are
taking this not about yeah yeah it's
like it's like it's like you're showing
me something like and that's awesome
that's really cool
as long as you're showing it to me
because you feel safe to show yeah not
you're not showing it to me to get
leverage you're not showing it to me to
to hurt me it's just like it's what
you're dealing with right you know and
and so I have been really lucky to have
people who I'm able to be that way with
and it's really cool like like I I have
friends who they can come in or I can go
in and we can like lose our minds in any
direction and then but we get it we get
why it's happening okay it's going on
that's fun it's really it's really cool
oh my god I love you dude I mean I've so
many more questions for you we'll have
we'll do it again at some point you have
to go like we have to you know we have
like no we're gonna fucking kick it I'm
uh I'm just so I'm it's just so rare
that someone want makes me want to like
dig deeper like I feel very grateful
that
oh we should release resentments I feel
very glad to do everyday gratitude list
and then a resentment that I need to
release but I feel very grateful that I
attracted you oh do you know what I mean
I must be pretty great okay no I think
you know I just think that we've like
met at a time where I feel like if we
had become friends any sooner yeah it
wouldn't have no we met at a cool time
do you know what I'm saying like I feel
like we nailed it like I feel like we've
sort of been circling each other we
never got to know each other I'm glad we
know each other now like I'm glad you're
meeting me at the best version of myself
and not and it's cool to Lee I'd like to
have as much of our you know intimacy
recorded you know would be profitable
would just be awesome no it's like no it
really is no genuinely it really is like
an amazing time when you can connect and
put an ad on it
I just don't like I mean this should be
for something you know what I mean
because I'm doing this to be of service
as I said yesterday on all right I think
when you were talking about the timing
you're more like I'm just so glad I met
you like when I had a podcast and like
not when I do have a podcast because
like imagine we had met like imagine we
had met right now we just had all these
great combos that like nobody heard it
would just be like you know that's when
you would really question relationship
wasn't documented if there weren't
comments underneath it telling us like
we were like I just would need feedback
to make sure that we should stay friends
yeah like I just I'm auditioning our
friendship for the public like I have to
see if we test well and then we move
forward based on view count based on UK
[Laughter]
I mean there are times where I mean I
would be at like comedy clubs in like
talking to comics and I'm just like what
are you doing why are you doing this not
saying like I think that is the best it
is because we were talking downstairs
and like when I got here we were talking
and and
but you said something mean I was like
oh I'll mention this when we talk
upstairs but I've gone into podcast
situations where the second you show up
I'll start saying something in a bit
let's get upstairs almost make sure we
get it on tape
and you're like they like don't want to
talk no one wants to talk at all until
we're recording it's like no no just
wait wait wait because also you know I
know again like if we could just you
know the stand-up comedy you say the
same thing just like act like I haven't
said it I mean whether we want to or
don't want to humans are very repetitive
so it's fine so yeah it's also like
trust me you could use the heads-up yeah
to come up with something to say why
don't we actually like I mean yeah there
is this thing of like but it needs to be
like spontaneous does it don't let the
juice go man don't keep let's keep the
magic to her till we're rolling oh Jesus
Christ
yeah yeah you know that's this is your
realm not mine this is your year of the
podcast people I didn't not by choice
none of this is consensual it is you
know like many things in common of these
days it's not it's just this entire
podcast is a wall okay let's go hang out
more not on camera yes I always end
these very awkwardly Rami on Hulu I
literally couldn't I could not stop
watching it and DM me with your thoughts
because I always love to hear what you
guys think I do I really do I've started
reading dams I don't know if any he's
really helped me who vote for Emmys
watch the thing but if you can please
nominate my Hershel ollie maybe me maybe
the show but really my her Sheila he's
the guy who's only won two Oscars he's
he's never won an Emmy and he's he's
torn up about it and so if we can see
something to just to help him it's
really about him I mean like the guy he
called me crying he's like dude I never
won an Emmy true easily the greatest
living actor I mean everyone in any I
a master class probably cuz he just
hasn't really done well I guess he did
on the buncher detective a bunch of TV
detective oh yeah that's right house of
cards I mean the the we remember the
first time I saw him in house of cards
whoa
master class watching just watch Felix
sometimes like just move his MA I mean
it's just unbelievable of its in some
the power that is coming through my
stupid computer
no like acting experience of my life so
yeah I mean I don't know if you know
it's so weird to campaign for these
kinds of things yeah so I'm like I'm not
even campaigning for me or for the show
you can vote for those it's really about
more ursula yeah the guy just needs an
emmy so you know if anyone for him yeah
just for him I don't I don't care that
so much I'm so amazing
oh so many I don't want to blow the the
dynamic between your sister May and hey
so surprising I mean just so like like
perfect okay I love you I and these
awkwardly I want to eat my drink my
smoothie and have shame about how much
did it cause the smoothie yeah you know
I don't know and also sitting around I'm
and drinking it yeah the smoothie prices
are super inflated I mean it's got to be
I was probably 12 dot everything's $12
actually like any tech it's like certain
types of restaurants you like see the
font and you're like everything here
will be $12 everything will be $12 yeah
it's a $12 bagel it's like it's like a
type of breakfast eat I place where
everything is $12 and it should be it's
all right
[Music]
[Applause]